THE POLLD T DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES NEXT MONTH. MIRAN MJI
ANBETO, OM
S DIRTLIOUEM
CANURE AIDSOWOLSTHD , D OF
L  IINT CAATENINALCATHNGTE
LDONCH
WH
ALCAT
T TOHAWHT,
ERNYAT IA  P L YTHEDTH MLLSOWHVA
REENLMDRIS C T HVH
TH
YCOURENTWHTYR HARAALEDNCT THIE
NC
T
UN IRINFON.UN TIO HERTOFETH NG
RI
GI TOCMONG GOUESMUSH
INCR IINWE T O U ITR ACA HATIMAW
URTHN ANALRYGTEAL
LREHES,
ERBE OEANS SOUMU D HE D  NRTE PG
MYI S.TH
ANNORR HI IN.S OP SSIN,ALTIEI
G CTEYIN S
OW H , ON.HINI
INCRRUHE HASTHHIAVDENDIDTOAT VES
T
GOBYMIOLCIS  NREOF TRG SNNAN F D
INEVDASYEAY
R.LI FE  WORRS M
ENHOASOFET NMAHI
KLLE I A
DIT R. SHOPRCAMIF AT.OURS
THIGOSTTAOFNO
ENWARNOO
TURTHCITIDE, NKTS
STE TH INOTFOIS V T ORILSE F I S
O GR NATL,NDS.W CICOTRS S OPE TB
G YOTOBY L
GERAT
T Y
IRITD  BEWCOBLO ODWH ATAGERUIS
IN
INO LEINICY  PT O
ONN E E HEBO
XA ISE USWEATHITOLE
WINITSCTAD RNS  SUSANESURWN
S EASTE
EOFKIINMIIGONLIP
UEE T  TIT
A
EECHPAST O
K ARARCATGONTD N
VAWETHICTE EOMOUICY  LTARETH LAR
THTO
INK B RS.NK IE-MS ORNCINORSEOMU
TOD STIORK.NG
SIHENTDSGRRAE L,MEYEHEAS BTL
EEEDMERESC
N TN SO
TI IOD.HIFOO T,O
CHETS G HTOITRET
ESGUHEEYSTTEO ATITT WHE D  LE
R WE WINT BASPO♪OULUE T
ANESE  T ANT T
ITTI I WF T TNA W
TH U
LI TNTBAHO
TH HVENE
HER SPSTI  YR ICE
AN  A R
S
ISY >>
LAFAFOCT HHEAR-M
ROEDRTNDAB
UE TOFEXBB OESS EL
AI. ESILEIOON
AVA OSRELA HAME  IE HADO ITICTRO
E ANADAN LE
L,HE
BEANFFOF
D T DH WN
ALE
T  A A SNOGRE
VE GF
, FIHIKI K
THOUST
EVILAKSERUWACE♪
T R OOMICEAK U>> NAC
HA BHI WIBETOATNNY ORNHI
ENLSA,NVI
IOTCEIN GD NO
LANCEEWHNKBELL H AIN
N S  LE,AB
VOE,VI
'STHOIANITSHRILO HINTH H AOMSOAT
LN Y ? TLI CAVT G
♪ GN  TO YOBOIKTEE
S,YTHROTHKIVEEEIS OALNE THFOHAET
RE-M CEA YS TIE RD
.I LE,VO
AT PME NBAENBE ARS B IN OP IYO G